A bang a boom, a bang,  boom, boom GO!
All right.
Hello everybody, my name is, Markiplier and welcome back to the 'West of Loathing' DLC reckonin' in gun manor. My cheeks
are still-- Ow, that fucking hurt. Ow, why did I do that? That hurt.
My cheeks are still puffy cause my, uhhh,
My teeth holes still hurt. I can't say my teeth hurt cause the holes where my teeth were hurt.
But, we're back in the manor. Oh, doing the funky little dance.
We're back in the manor and we need to go, if I remember correctly--are we on the second floor or the third floor?
Thi-- we're on the second floor. Okay, let's go back up to the third floor. We only just started
exploring this area Mr. Gun and Mrs. Gun. Okay.
Oh, Mr. Guns manliness room. Well, I'm a man--hi. Oh,
This guy doesn't notice you approaching until you're right next to him. He yelps in surprise and drops his glass on the floor, uh..,
then squints unsteadily at you. Then he takes a ma-maraschino cherry
[Confused] What the fuck..? Then he takes it--sorry [Chuckles]
Sorry, something very weird just happened off to the side.
Then he takes a maraschino cherry from a bowl on the bar cart and throws it at your head. Hey! Stop that.
Ha, ha, sorry. Jus' makin' sure you're not one'a them ghosts.
He drops another cherry into a fresh glass, and pours a lot of whiskey on top of it.
Are you one of the museum employees? Mm-hmm. Yup. That's me. What are you doing in here? Hidin'! Buddy, I dunno if
maybe you didn't notice. But this house? This house. This house has got ghosts in it! You don't say.
Whoooole bunches of 'em! All over! So, I don't know 'bout you, but I'm stayin' right here, where it's nice an' drunk.
I mean safe. Wouldn't you rather get out of here? Nah, all the booze-- Uh, that is, boos.
I'm really scared of when ghosts go "boo." You know? They'll get me if I leave this room.
There aren't any ghosts between this room and the exit. So you say. Said. That's what you said.
But, they're ghosts! That could be anywhere. Except in here? 'Zactly!
I ain't leaving without a guarantee that those ghosts won't grab me on the way out. We could disguise you.
[Confused af] I have a shower curtain? Why do I have a shower curtain here?
Here, look. We'll use this white shower curtain to disguise you as a ghost. Then they won't bother you on your way out. That's uh-
That's a mighty fine idea, but...
He tosses back his drink and pours another. But umm... Oh, eyeholes! That curtain's got no holes for eyes,
I won't be able to see! Heh. I'm starting to think you don't actually want to leave. Nooooo, what'd give you that idea?
It's terrible in here. [Laughs] Shoot some holes in the curtain.
You narrow your eyes at him and blast some holes in the curtain with your pistol. Okay,
okay, jeez. I get the picture.
He grabs an armload of bottles from the cart, pulls the shower curtain over his head, and staggers out the door. Good.
Man, he's lucky, I could have put it on his head and then shot the eyeholes.
Then he wouldn't have been not too hap-- [Laughs] -- then he would've be a ghost.
Ohhhhhh, nevermind. [Chuckles]
The museum employee has drunk a lot of this carts' cun-contents, but there's a few bottles left. Okay. Manley's Finest Cotton Candy Schnapps.
Okay, cool. It's a humidor full of cheap cigars. Oh, I got a cheap cigar.
This is for a cigar for people who want, for some reason, to appear to have spent a lot of money on a
disgusting habit without actually spending a lot of money on it. Okay, grab another one, okay.
You've got plenty of them at this point. I don't know. Could I have more? From the smell of it Mr.
Gun mostly burned garbage in this thing. Mkay, let's go. What's this? Weird.
If you were going to commission a painting of swords,
you'd think at least f-- [Stammers] you'd -- they'd look-- you'd  thi-- least think-- you'd at le-- you'd think you'd at least ask for nice swords.
I am dumb. [Correct]
Bowling is g-- Uh, oh.
No, wait. Oh wait. No. No, I know what that's gonna do. This poster is clear in its artistic content, but not very imaginative.
Oh, no. Big red button. Nothing happens. You sure?
You sure? Okay.
This is where the bowling balls would come out of if this thing worked. [Re-read, Mark lol]
Broken, it's not supposed to be flying around even a little bit. Alright.
Okay. I'll fight it. Got the jump on him. Yeah, I'm not sure about that.
But, uh, okay, sure.
Mr. Cal D and then-- do I have like a heavy bullet?
Eh, this'll get it. [Aggressively] BANG! [Laughs] Okay-y-y.
God, I'm too powerful for this DLC. I really am. I got a bowling pin.
Carry this around we'll save you the trouble of hurling your enemies all the way down a bowling lane to hit them with it.
Yeah, okay. That makes sense.
Hooorayy!
I ge-  What do I have as a-
I got a jumbo shrimp fork. That's got the moxie I'm gonna keep that.
[Sings idiotically while character walks] XD
Oh, good. Th XR fi-- 85 was complete trash.
[Laughs to himself]
All right. Oh, what the frick? What? What? WhAt? Why is there another one?
Awe, that didn't actually kill it.
Awe! That's that didn't act-- oh, there we go. Yeah.
Whoaly shit. [All one word apparently]
Gary, go easy on 'em. Bowling ball chunk.
This chunk of a bowling ball isn't big enough to do anything other than throw at
something. This is useful in combat. Deals damage equal to your muscle.
Okay, sure, whatever. I could've sworn the bowling his good side was gonna turn into boo.
Oh. [Laughs]
Like this room.
Wow. You hope you never meet a live duck this big.
It's sickening, killing a helpless sofa and stuffing its carcass as a grisly trophy. [Dying inside] Ah~
Shut up. Oh, shut up. One of the mooses eyes is loose, pop it out.
Oh. Now, it's really got its eye on you. Shut up.
This glass is either-- this is either a prosthetic eye made of glass or a very macabre marble. A macarble.
Ah, shut up. This is just the head of a teddy bear. They didn't even remove the tag!
All right. So many polyesters died just to decorate rooms like this.
Right. These antlers are made out of papier-mache apparently by somebody who had never seen antlers before. A whole rack a-
A whole rack of bowling--
I was looking at the guy playing five finger fillet, but then I saw the--
T-the Goblin. Alright, if they were billiards trophies there'd be an easier pun to make. Wait-
Okay...
Uh, 'kay? Okay, we'll cover the knife marks. Ah, there's a goblin head mounted like a trophy on the wall! This would be positively barbaric
barbaric, if not for the fact that the Goblin seems pretty okay with it. BOO! Ha ha ha! Pretty good. I am getting you, huh human?
Uh, wow yes! Very much to getting me! Nice! What is did happening to you? Did Mr.
Gun hunting you and to cutting head off? No no! Mr. Gun a good human man is being, very friends! Inside one of his bowling ball bags, my spore to growing only head room! Mr.
Gun to finding me and hanging me up here, for to chatting with. Great guy. Wow weird. Okay.
Goodbye, you can tell this is fake because it isn't floating around the room setting stuff on fire
This is just a photograph of a fish. Mr. Gunn was apparently really liberal with his definition of trophy
Alright, this ghost is dressed up as a traditional Safari hunter with the pith helmet and big white moustache the colonel and those weird
Khaki trousers that make it look like your bud has wings. He's inspecting mr. Guns trophy collection, but doesn't seem particularly impressed. Hi
I'm mom floor thumper ding. Hmm Todd. I'm sure Lord Huston cam Denton at your service
What happened here if you don't mind my asking?
Not at all. Not at all though. It is a very exciting story. Hey what I was hunting lions and the plains of the Serengeti
As one of the blighters got the better of me. Wow, you're eaten by a lion. That sounds pretty exciting. Yes
Well not eating this such sneaky bugger crept into the camp and pushed a stack of ammunition crates over on me. Oh
Maybe I can help you
Help me do what? Well help you with whatever's keeping you as a ghost, though
Now I say it I guess there isn't much I can do to help you get revenge on a line. Oh, no
No, it isn't about revenge. That's keeping me here. Good for that line. I say turnabout is fair play and all that. Hey what?
Though I do wish he'd done it in a matter they made for a better story
So why are you ago sin? It's because of my one true regrets. I never faced the most dangerous game
I am definitely not going to help you hunt people. What no, no, no the most dangerous board game
Nobody was ever willing to play against me a Bally shame here. What what's the game?
He leads you over to a small table on which has laid a board of alternating red and black squares with little wooden disks
Painting red and black as well
checkers
Checkers jumpin scatter as the ghost stabs two large hunting knives into the center of the board
knife checkers Oh
What are the rules do you know how to play checkers? Yes. Do you know how to stab someone in the hand with a knife?
Yes
Saul's do you really need to know?
Okay, I'll play
You went yank. Ooh, one of the knives out of the board and Lord Houston instructs you to hold it left-handed the rules
Are you may only attack your opponent's hand and only when they are over the board displays checkers are played from where they land
But attacking the board directly as a foul which Awards the opponent a stab free turn
it appears to be primarily a game of concentration quick movements and fainting I
Need 50 muscle to play aggressively I
Have 50 muscle. I guess I didn't think I had that much muscle
Yeah, I do that you start out the game by attacking quickly and fiercely to establish dominance
And keep your opponent from developing his pieces. The strategy is somewhat affected, but Lord Austin doesn't scare easily
He manages to feign a few pieces past your guard. You enter the mid game more or less evenly match play
intelligently in
The mid game you focus more on the checkers than on your knife work
Maneuvering into position for some big gains new long-term you suffer a few minor Nicks and cuts put a well positioned for the end game-play
craftily
Lord goostin spots a hole in your defenses he faints left then quickly slides one of his pieces into the gap and
Into your trap this move his moves his hand into the just the position
You need to attack it with the hard downward stab
He easily Yanks his hand out of the way and your knife hits one of the pieces on its edge
Flipping it across the board to land neatly in this back rank
King me Oh
I say it's a foul to attack the board
Sure, but I wasn't was I I attacked your hand and you dodged that's all you sneaky blighter you play continues
But with the King behind lord houston's line you clean up fairly quickly. All right lad I concede
Marvelous play what well done. He gives you a smart salute and fades away into nothingness 180 XP
Whoo?
I did it I guess man my cheeks hurt I taste blood
It's not a good I've been talking all day, and I should not have been I did a stream today not a good idea
Pretty much everything I've done
Everyone hold on to your tits everyone. Hold on to your buckets. It's a fucking switch
Here's a spittoon ear of bright shiny beautiful spittoon. Oh
Boy oh yeah, come to Papa. What are you doing? Huh?
Nothing. What are you doing?
looking at someone who's kneeling next to a spittoon with the apparent intention of
sticking
Diamond you Jam your hand into the spittoon up to the shoulder and find nothing the brass bucket is shiny and clean
outside and in cleanness
The museum staff wasn't washed it it looks brand-new. Are you crying? No?
I'm fine you're crying
Okay. Well, I'll just be over here. Whatever you're done lying on the ground in a fetal position in hugging a spittoon
No
Okay, fine, whatever grab one you got this what you inspect and take the best one, what's the point of life I
now get while these ghosts just stick around long after they're dead because life was just a disappointment why can't death
also just be one big fucking
Disappointment god damn it. Fuck me. Okay, here we go
I got a wobbly billiards cube
The thing about people who buy billiards tables is that they are almost never the kind of people who will properly maintain their cues
This cue does not provide evidence to the contrary
negative-1 moxie
Great looks company too bad. You're too busy to sit down and table bears the scars of many unco stirred beverages or whatever
Whatever. What's the point of life? Hi hard billiards. This is both the biggest and dumbest poster you've ever seen
Huh? There's a trapdoor in the ceiling over here too bad. You aren't like 11 feet tall
Good to know. Hey, buddy. Hey, how's it going? I ain't interested in chitchat
Fella just billiards step up or shut up
All right, you pull out your cue and the ghost nods and racks the balls
He utterly trounces you you just can't seem to make the balls go where you intended
That was a sad showing as I have ever seen. Let me see that cue. Yeah, that's your problem
This thing's about as straight as the bankers handshake
Well, you're gonna need to lay this back it to true if you want a chance against me lathe, huh?
I know my way around a lathe one of the most lethal
things ever
So he is tack or whatever
Okay. Well that was mr. Guns room. What about mrs. Guns room. The store is locked and no earthly force can open it
Well, maybe whole team of horses, but good luck getting them up the elevator. Okay, knock knock. Yes, who is it?
This gun a monthly fun burning, but you with the ghost
Extermination people. Yes, ma'am Florence Cunningham Cunningham goes to nine leaves and services. Mom Fleur is my assistant. Come here
What who's the country?
Who's the county license go center? Here you mere you okay fine
I guess have you been able to exterminate all the ghosts? I still feel?
for haunted
Eleven of them left according to the scanner. We're still working on the man
Don't you worry, you can count on us the whole rise. Please. Let me know when you've finished
All right, sure, whatever. Okay music room. Have they been in there?
No, I have not. Hello crazy
This woman doesn't seem to be interested in anything other than cranking the hurdy-gurdy
Okay, you definitely disconnect the crank from the hurdy-gurdy without alerting the woman's attention
But it turns out you needn't have bothered she continues to turn the crank blank-eyed with even nothing attached
you grab the end of the crank and pull her very slowly to the gift shop where you find a Victrola to plug her into
problem solved Oh
Weird, uh, freak am I?
What
Huh
What?
She seems just as happy years. He was before it's nice to have a calling. What what? Oh
Hey, thanks for asking me from the hedge maze. Hello, either. I never asked you what you do here
I've already forgotten. I run this token smashing machine
If you buy one to the commemorative tokens from that other machine over there
I can put it in this machine here to rule it out flat
Well flatter and sample with our logo on one side and a fun picture on the other. Can I interest in you Arnold? Sure
Oh, you need to token first. You can buy them from their little machine over there on the next counter
Why don't you sell them yourself? She looks cheapest alone
Let me have access to the tokens apply anymore because I have too much fun smashing them
Ok
Sign says genuine gun manners souvenir token make your wishes come true. Just three hundred fifty meet
How do I negotiate a better deal with a machine?
Well, I got dickering. So let's do it in a staggering a display of business acumen
You convinced me to give you discount
Okay, cool, yeah, alright, let's see what it does Hey here we go great a love runner this thing is so satisfying
What picture do you want? Ooh?
I want a cool pistol a sweet. Oh cool pistol good choice someday
It'll make a lot of people uncomfortable. If you tell me you think pistols are cool, but here in 1895
Hahaha, she takes your token pussy machine happily turns the crank. It makes a loud grinding noise and
Your token drops out and into the slot somewhat longer and thinner hey
That's pretty good. Ya
Want to smash another one? Yeah, I'm good. I'm gonna quit this one. It's pretty good
Goes in my off hand. So it's not the sweet-smelling flowers. It's a fucking gun token
Ha ha ha as if I needed to be more powerful
There's an old frame photograph of mrs. Gun on the wall with a little explanatory plaque underneath
Ok, the photograph is a of a young mrs. Gun smiling as she accepts of
fancy trophy from man in a suit a frowning man wearing a lab coat is standing behind her the plaque reads Terry got an
Assistant accepting the 1869. Why didn't we think of that Award for Excellence in inventing from the National Academy of profitable Sciences?
Zephyr inventing the gun I guess having greeted you he's now stands perfectly silent Oh
Ask for some info. Oh, hi. Thanks again for freeing me from that book
You're still kind of at markzware the engravings pressed into your face
I'm hoping that they fade with time but if not, I can always quiz myself while shaving
So what do you do? I
Provide information want some yeah. Sure. Great this one I'm here for what would you like to know mrs
Gun her full name is Teresa
Olivia gun blah blah blah born in 1847 blah blah blah
Unpleasant disagreement blah blah blah invent gun blah blah blah blah blah
married husband and blah three daughters
Okay, blah blah blah not too loud to know very private person blah blah historical foundation blah blah locked herself four years ago
Okay, how about the family blah blah married damn staple remover blah blah inventor of the staple remover blah blah take her last name
He wanted to call as I mentioned office numbers blah blah
Annoyed that people called it after him instead three daughters Dorothy Blanche and Rose
blah blah Dan vanished in 1889
Shortly after Rose is born the blah blah certainly seem to have killed by Vince blah blah blah blah blah
No, ransom note blah blah never the same start blaming it on ghosts blah blah blah. No ghost activity here until just the other day
Okay
Gun manner, isn't it amazing? Mr
Gun had it built in mid to late 70s blah blah blah coal filed Boulder bowling alley blah blah library blah blah blah
Historical Society blah blah dumbwaiter blah never come out of a room since blah blah telephone house intercoms
Okay, how about rocks great. I know ton of stuff about rocks specifically igneous rocks and granted in particular
Did you know that granite contains at least 17 to 25 percent quartz?
Which makes it useful as a resistor in all kinds of magical devices
Weird tell me another one bran is frequently used as a building material due to its size strength and pleasant gray color
Go for it again. Keep going. How about another one. There we go. More more more more
More more more more more more more more more more more
More more more more more more more more. Okay. He's repeating himself. Okay. Goodbye
No one here. No one here
Hey
the guy from the bar card is leading heavily against the display of shot glasses with
Different names etched on them a sign on this display reads
Personalized shot glass is 1200 meet the guy picked up with a bottle set behind the display and fills the shot glass labeled Edwin
Say your name Edwin. He didn't answer. Alright
Okay. Oh, it's you my hero and Savior. Oh, well, leave me alone. I'm busy apparently
Alright fine. Goodbye
This is where they all go. Then listen here. The carriage door is locked, but you've got the key unlock it then. Oh
Okay, hello, maybe there's something useful in this cabinet there is there is something useful
You got a nearly empty herbicide can and a handful of nails great, what do I do with those
This Kansas says it'll instantly kill all plants, but it feels like there's only one plants worth of deadly chemicals left
Time--was would have been Brad's but nowadays man does not live by bread alone
Okay
pair of old hedge clippers
Alright your uncle used to refer to these things as shrub scissors these ones look a pretty effective tetanus delivery device
Okay. Don't know why one would need that. But all right, whew, they they had their own custom stagecoaches
Okay, I'll talk to that guy in a second. Is that a lathe? Hang on? Wait a second
This guy's slouching around here smoking a cigarette hi-yah. Hey
Do you work here? Are you a parking attendant or something? Yeah, I guess I validate people's parking in that
Can you I'm on break? Oh
Well, really everyone's on break kinda what do you mean?
Well whole bunch of ghosts showed up and one of the carriages all of a sudden everyone's either hiding out or kidnapped
Hi, I got here in a ghost carriage. Oh, man
Did I die somewhere not notice am ia ghost the guy jabs your forehead with one finger. Ow
Nope convinced him to get back to work
Is that kind of there gonna be enough?
Okay. Well, you should probably get back to work now
Yeah, why is that cuz I'm gonna rescue all the other employees and if they come back and catch you slacking off, they'll be ticked
Jeez, okay, fine. Just let me finish the smoke before you get all heroic
Okay. All right. Goodbye. Then see pile of loose boards build something hammering nails why?
Why would I need it Oh
No, Oh No
And it's too silly shut up go to hell so lave
And maybe you can make that billiards queue less wobbly or I could wrap myself up in a horrible industrial accident
You lathe rinse and repeat. Oh fuck you until the queue is fixed balance. Billy is cute
Ah, that's nice. I like that
Is that more Moxie than I've got in my jumbo? Nope? No, sir. Okay here I go you'll be
Diddly did Liddy. How do I get back to where I was before?
I don't even remember. I gotta go back into the the maze at some point, but I've got too much to do here
So I might as well just skedaddle up to the third floor go back into the billiard room and challenge
you you
You yeah you with this. All right, let's do this buddy. Let's do this. You pull out your cueing the ghost nods and racks
He proceeds to crush you something feels wrong like your cues and connecting with the brawl properly the ghost shakes his head
You're totally new to this ain't yet? You got a chalk your cue chalk
Huh? Can I borrow yours? Mine's ghost? Chalk wouldn't work. Dang it. Oh, okay. None for me. Then what a big waste of time
What a big lumpy waste of time. Okay, let's go back to the first floor
I feel like there was something in the basement that I need. So I feel also like my face is swelling up
But that's okay. I'm not too worried about it. It was there something here
Wasn't there something like in the science room that I needed. I don't remember
Okay, all right here mess with them
Maybe not. Maybe I'm just a fool
Maybe I'm nothing but a fool
I think I'm nothing but a fool right there, but there's got to be something else than I need lard larder largest
Shelf is full of pots and pan. Wait. There's a larder and a pantry Oh Oh
a
Pantry oh
Okay, this ghost is running around like crazy
Or hovering around like crazy searching the racks for pants or trousers if you prefer, but we say pants here in the western territories
He seems too preoccupied to take any notice of you
Disguise yourself as pants. Oh
You sneakily concealed yourself among the pants and pop out as he approaches boo I'm pants. Ah
Geez, bunny who's nearly scared to death out of me
Sorry, I was just wondering what you were doing. Well, I thought it'd be obvious
I'm looking for a pair of pants, but you don't have any legs. Oh
I know it's what do you want pants for?
nostalgia, no, I
See kind of pants you're looking for the kind without legs legless pants
Well, I can't wear regular pants, you know legs would just flop around and they'd be dumb
I guess you have a point God you lose your legs. Anyway, oh, geez, it's really embarrassing
I don't mind. Well, see I didn't have a proper holster from a gun. So I was carrying it tucked in my belt Oh
Trigger snagged when you went to draw it, huh?
Right. Well, I mean it gets worse
I was wearing one of those gun belts with the slots all around for you to stick bullets in you know, oh, man
the chain reaction blew off the entire
Wow, so, that's how you died
Yes, that is how I died
Okay. I'll keep an eye out for some legless pans for you. Thanks. I really appreciate it
Well, I don't think I'm gonna get any here. Am I?
Probably not also they don't make sense. So I don't know what that's all about
Laura door. Oh
Hello
decorative fancy French stuff caviar
Tootin caviar say food. You don't like wait a second
One of these string beans is exactly 1 point 2 3 3 7 inches in diameter. They must have packed the beans length
Okay, hello Oh weird, what do you what you thought was a framed photograph is actually a window
Why does the Larter have a window and why is this ghost standing motionless in front of it as if you were a framed photograph?
Excuse me. Hello grab them by the shoulders and shake them
Ok
please
cease this activity of ones
sorry, I got a little carried away how
About telling me who you are. Ah, you do not recognize me. Jean-francois are there
No what I knew simply mimicking the photograph would not be sufficient
Without it wholly anyone know I'm the famous France man ever to visit can mana have a lot of Frenchmen visiting
besides having z-direction
distinction of being the most famous Frenchman to visit gun Manor
I'm also the first Frenchman to visit John Manor and the last is well. Oh
gosh, did I I was posing for the photograph and
Commemorate my visit here and that fool of a photographer fault of when preparing vegan bother flowers
Thought of how he left a bullet in it. I see that must have this photograph
Such a faces mine must the languish in obscurity
Right. I don't know if you find it wasn't there a box of photos in the basement
Wasn't there one maybe there's some pants in the basement - no
No, no. All right. Hang on. Wait. No am I on?
I'm on the first floor the basement the cellar was it wasn't this look through them
You got a photo of largest guy? Okay, cool. No. Wait, hang on. Let me look at it. First. Never know what's gonna do
Nope, nothing. Ok, nevermind no point to that. I guess I'll just drop it off
swollen cheeks and all
Hello, I found an old photograph
My mother yeah Oh marvelous
What our resemblance?
Yeah, it's pretty decent pic good thing light travels faster than bullets now
My image will not be lost. His their averages of time merci beaucoup, my friend
He hangs a photo in the window. It dissipates into nothingness auf wiedersehen
Okay
That's terrible. That's not good at all. All right, whatever
Okay. Well, that was good. I'm glad I did
Now I've done this can keep it together mum Fleur spices
You got that under control grab a chili pot and put it on the burden was I supposed to do
You're trying to make chili without a gun in it. So you have to remember to skip the gun part. Oh
You shake a heaping helping of chili spices into the pot the next step is beans
Unfortunately find yourself embarrassingly beamless devoid of legumes sans had a coughs as the French would say it better go find some beans then
Doesn't their beans in the larder
Did not get a can of beans. I got a can of beans but I need to open the can of beans I
It's in the basement again. It's all it's all connected. I should have gone back there. I should have gone back. It's all connected
This is this thing here
All right
Here we go
Get the right tin, san you got some stuffing make a silent earth
You drill a hole in each end of the can and carefully remove the beans
When you soak the stuffing in a vat of acoustic dampening chemicals and carefully jammed in the can voila
Silent. Ow, this is a can of stuffing designed to make it easier for you to shoot people at Thanksgiving dinner without getting caught. Oh
Okay, I'll silent my pistol you fix this Islander to the barrel of your be fouled pistol
All right
Okay, maybe I should have silent did the worst
All right, I
Got that now. I don't know what that did
But at least I got the means and if I got the beans that means I can make me some chili
Tomo make me some chili
Beans I thought I did done get the beans
Wasn't what I got beans. Oh
man, I
Thought I had that all right, what's in here?
Oh, whoa, nothing bunch of nothing a bunch of bullshit and Nothingness woes in here, Moo
I don't know
Hello
Still working on it
to hell with your chili and also you
Really tickled my fancy really just really just dick, 'old me really tickled me I
Love this game. I love this game so much. I think I got everything there. I think I got everything in the gallery. I
Think oh you yes, ah
Let's go let's go somewhere else. Oh wait. No, let's go. All right
Read a book Oh, what do I need to read? I've forgotten
Okay, whatever whatever whatever whatever whatever whatever whatever I'm gonna ask Florence, what's up
Ten ghosts left on the premises two on the first floor four in the second four in the third
But my my current sounds like a real complicated one. I know a real simple solution. Oh
No, no. No, we're not gonna shoot anybody. There was some book that I needed
Can you help me with library stuff I was a bug on specific topic. Oh, never mind
Oh
I don't know where to start. I don't know what to do
Lost I've lost
And I'm so scared. There's gotta be something here
Oh
Wait
Ah-ha, were you able to find me a new eye. Yes, kind of how kind. Thank you very much
She steaks a glass from you and puts it in whereupon it falls through her and onto the floor. She cuts
She picks it up. Oh dear. It's a little too physical. Yeah, I wasn't certain that. This would work. Don't worry
This is easily fixed. Do you have a hammer? I can borrow a hammer?
Yeah
That'll do nicely. Thank you
She takes an error and pleases the glass eye on her desk and smashes it too with a precise crack. Ah, perfect
She gives you back the clamor and plucks the ghost of the glass eye from the shattered fragments
After blowing the dust off of it she tucks it into her eye socket that fits much better. Does it work?
Well, now you mention it. I can't actually see with it. Is it is the ghost of a glass eye after all?
Oh dear. This won't do at all. What a shame. You know, I don't really understand why your eyes still missing
What do you mean? Well I always assumed when someone loses an arm or something. It just sticks around as an owner arm ghost
That's why people say they can feel it itching sometimes because he's still got an arm there, but it's a ghost
It's even called phantom limb syndrome
So logically if the rest of you becomes a ghost after that, it would hook right back up
But then where did my I go?
Maybe I got pushed back inside your head the ghost thinks about it for a second shakes your head
No
that seems wait what I do think I felt something just then she shakes her head just
Again, my goodness gracious
Keep going. It's like one of those puzzles where you trying to get the marble in the hole
She bends her head forward and continues shaking you can almost hear a faint rattling sound and then a plop
- straightens back up blinking with towards you did it. Well me. Thank you so much, dear
I never would have thought of that. No problem. Have a nice pot time in heaven or wherever the ghost gives you friendly waves
And fades out of sight. That's it then Wow
wonderful
Did you figure out how to make a good old exploding cigar one that doesn't turn fun and funeral
Oh, I can't even make basic wordplay funny. Well, it was kind of clever
Never mind. All right. I've got cigars. I just don't know how to turn it into explodey cigars
How do I do that?
Puff off you light the cigar and take a single puff
It turns out a single puff is enough to make you stink for the rest of the day. Oh
Good great, gross. Oh great. Glad I did that
Okay, good. Great. Alright. Well, that was fun. Glad I did that. Well, okay. Wait, hang on did I go in the restroom?
Yeah, I did
Well, then, where are the hacking hacking tits? Oh, I wasn't done upstairs. That's right
I got I got thrown out of here. Oh, whoops
alright, this is a bassoon and you know what they say, it makes an ass out of n and and
What?
Hey, I hate you I
Hate you
A fancy new electric floor lamp a musty decaying pile of old music books face them
Almost all the books are dirty and rotten my moth-eaten and fall apart at the touch
You do find a copy of Dueling Banjos in reasonable shape though
Okay. This is a book of sheet music for the classic song Dueling Banjos. There's a library call number written on the spine. I
Think that's gonna help me very much
Very very much sheet music you got blank sheet music play Dueling Banjos
I can't play Dueling Banjos by myself. I don't have enough arms Florence
So I only play the bagpipe but not very well if it's a bagpipe bagpipe, how do you know? Hey, what about you Gary?
Hello. Hello what you know how to play the piano?
What it is having so many square teeth. Well, that's wrong
That's an error
All right, never mind then. Hello. Hi
This is the ghost of an orchestra conductor unless easily goes to someone pretending to be an orchestra conductor either way
He's very agitated about something or he conducting flight of the bumblebee
Sorry to interrupt but I can't actually hear the music. What are you conducting?
It's the finale of the year 1812 solemn overture by Tchaikovsky
Tchaikovsky. Oh yes, the 1812 overture. Sure
Well, that wouldn't have would have been my second guess or is your orchestra like double ghosts or something? What?
Oh, I see, you know, there's no Orchestra. I merely have this piece of music a rhythmic rut
Irrevocably lodged in my head. It has been nagging at me incessantly ever since my death
This is just a guess. But did you die during a performance of the 1812 overture? That is very correct?
Very astute of you and the finale that piece features and a real actual canons, right?
Is that how you died?
If it was my fate to be slain by a piece of music canons would have been far preferable to my utter
farcical demise
What happened the overture requires several cannons?
Because it is impossible to load a single kin and quickly enough to fire as the score demands
However, the stage where we performed on could not have borne the weight. What did you do?
I was not informed of the difficulty until it was far too late to make any changes
Transpired that the stage manager decided it would be sufficient to give a box of bullets to the tube
You were shot by a tuba I was shot
Well, no wonder you ended up as a ghost
Oh
It isn't the ridiculousness of my death that troubles me really accidents happen as with any of the Performing Arts a colleague of mine was
Decapitated by an errant cymbal during a performance of fagot but got Paganini's violin concerto
Number one such are the risks we take for our art. Gosh. The problem is what that the 1812 overture is
Finale is a very dramatic and energetic piece with this music constantly playing itself in my head
I have been utterly unable to find any piece
I'll see if I can think of a way to help
Alright, well, I could play the Dueling Banjos, but I don't know how I'm gonna go to the library and take care of this
Right away because I think this is gonna give me something to debate with the lady. Wait a minute
Wait a minute here. I was on the wrong floor
I need to go to the library which is on the second floor. My cheeks hurt something fierce, but I'm gonna finish this episode out
Can you all be with library stuff found a book you might want to back?
Ok
investigate aha Dueling Banjos dual law
duly noted
Let's read this bad boy. Oh
Hell, yeah, you're reasonably well-informed about the specific subset of gun law pertaining to duels and duel adjacent activities
Alright, cool
Awesome, that was totally worth my time
Hell, yeah
alright, let's go to the
This floor this floor right here, yeah. Yeah, I
Remember where you are? You're not gonna make yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I was good there. I know let's go
Did you get a crash course and do law I sure did swell
The only thing I didn't really understand is when it's legal to banish your opponent to the Shadow Realm, okay
Well, that didn't come up in my case. So don't worry about it. Great
Let me just do a quick review a duels legal provided is doing exactly two people at a specific career range time and place using
the same or at least
Essentially similar weapons and they have to either face each other down or quick and quick draws the opponent a time moment or do 10?
Paces turn and fire between is that right? That's suggestive it. Yes
So I guess let's start with telling you telling me the facts of the case and I'll interrupt you rudely if I have any questions
Alright, but if you push me on trivial nonsense, I'll get mad and you'll have to start over
That's fair. Go ahead. All right
MacCready and tim's burry got into an argument in a saloon on the evening of June 17th
Apparently Tim's very accused Macready of cheating at poker
Okay, the bartender yelled at them to take it outside
But since it was dark out they agreed to meet for a duel the next day then that would be the 18th
You said yes, June
1818 78
Okay, go on
Well the next day they both showed up shortly before noon in the squared off about thirty feet from each other when Newton struck Macready
Fired fast enough the Tim's Barry didn't get a shot off on account of having his head shot off
That's pretty much the long and the short of it. I
Don't have to ask you some more details on that
Go ahead. What weapons were they using MacCready had a 45 caliber Single Action Army revolver
Tim's Bernie had an older model 36 caliber cap-and-ball Navy revolver, which he loaded with paper cartridges instead of backing gun powder by hand
Objection, those are significantly different weapons. Are you kidding me?
They're both pistols a modern cartridge revolver bursting an antique cap and ball loader
Ridiculous that antique was in production until 1873 and was considered one of the most reliable in popular six-shooters in the territories
Furthermore the restriction against differing weapons and duel is about pistols versus rifles or the proverbial knife in a gunfight
Whereas a more recent example a nitwit to argue the law against a professional attorney. Geez, that's a bit harsh
We're done here. Get out. No, right. Let's try that again
Hey now use
That's clearly duh you all right. Let's go. All right go on I have
Questions plus the name of the saloon already. I got another one. What day of the week
- the grumpy on a Monday both see I want
Some mouse or another argument there isn't much to tell the other places had already get fooled in their hands
So they weren't paying attention tense
Very suddenly accused Merck routing of a dirty dirty cheating varmint and McCready September II was just sore because you've been losing all night
Okay been accused of it once or twice before
Reno's gambling town a young guy on the rough part of it getting accused of cheating by a sore loser when you're on a lucky
streak depart for the course
but if McCready out a history of cheating
It would be irrelevant because the reason for the duels immaterial to the legality of the duel itself motive isn't an issue here
But remember I warned you about ticking me off of stupid digressions. This is an excellent example
Objection, this is extremely relevant relevant. Ah what this is extremely relevant if McCready was a hit bejeweled cheater
It's likely they would have cheated in the duel as well
now somehow you're gonna prove that McCready was a habitual poker cheat 17 years after the fact how exactly
What form of the mirrors? Alright? Well that did I knew that was going nowhere. All right, I'm gonna listen to my gut on this
Because I'm not just gonna do the objection if it just says objection because that's dumb. Oh, here we go or go on go
I have questions
that everyone what happened for details Oh
Fire - exactly noon far too soon as the church bells trucks. Yes
It's what I just said if you got a point of maker you just stalling
Well, yeah because they didn't count did they?
Objection, but that can but Creedy fired at the wrong time. What are you talking about?
He fired it exactly noon with the church bells. There are witnesses. That's right
He fired at o'clock noon, but the Stute the duel is set for high noon. Ah
See I listened to my instinct
Was something wrong here?
They aren't the same thing High Noon is just when the Sun is at his highest point in the sky
Depending on geography and the time of the year, it can be hours different from o'clock noon
MacCready fired early in makes a duel illegal. So what do you say to that counselor? Felicity gives you a slow smile
I've got to hand it to you prosecutor front ding
You're a lot better at this than I was giving you credit for that's a good thought you had there
There's just one problem with it. Oh, what's that? I already thought it'd take that
She hurls a small book at you what you just barely managed to catch. You got that nautical Almanac. What the heck is this?
I
Did my homework when I was preparing for that trial my legal homework since at the time I was expecting there to be an actual
Trial not a gunfight
What you're holding there is a nautical Almanac for the year 1878
There are book marks if you'd like to do the math for yourself
But if you look up solo noon aka High Noon for June the 18th and make the adjustment for Reno's longitude
What do you think you get you have got to be kidding me? That's right. Mr. Prosecutor
12 o clock p.m. Precisely
Well, damn nice try though, I mean that sincerely that's all my ammo
I can't think of any other way to disprove McCready's innocence. As far as I can tell it was a fair duel
Yes, and that's me with the guilt of an innocent man's death on my hands an innocent man's death
You sure are good at repeating things people. Say what if you didn't die say well now well, you didn't actually see the execution
Right. Yes. Well, I was indisposed you might say being dead and all so you don't actually know whether or not it happened
Oh, come on. Look. I appreciate the effort, but you're barking at the moon
Nancy don't go anywhere
Let me ask you something. Oh wait
See was a trial
Can you tell me about Macready gunfighter?
Thing else I'm good enough numbers another question
Why did he invoke trial by combat? I was mighty surprised
Let me tell you the only hair can figure is it was damn full sense of gunfighter pride or something?
like that was the only form of justice he was willing to submit himself to I have another question was a trial right after the
Duel, no Rena's like that
But it did have a proper courthouse murder charge trial didn't start till the 25th so much for the right to a speedy trial
Huh? I
Have another question when was the execution?
Well, we held the trial by combat on the 26th and those Friday they don't execute prisoners on the weekend
So presumably it would have been the following Monday the 29th in the morning
What with setting up the gallows and letting a crowd gather they usually happen in the afternoon around 3:00. I have another question
I'll be back. I need to do my research. Okay, I have this Almanac is this gonna help me?
Is the Almanac gonna help me look up a date on it look up a date
June July
Pick a day, how about
25th, right
Those when McCready's trial started no, no special. Look of a date
July
Day 26 thursday Felicity Wainwright was killed by trial nothing astronomically significant about it
June
17th see there was a moon and something between new and full
Good god, this is complicated. This is so complicated that
Was the day McCready perform. The fight high noon message is fine in to see me
Okay
Well, is there something else is she mentioned some other date? I don't know why the 29th
Okay, I guess I could look up the 29th, but I don't know what that's gonna do. Let's see
it's gonna be my
wait a minute corny this there was a total eclipse of the Sun that day centered right over the western territories and with the
Totality at 2:47. That's a hell of a thing. Okay. What does that mean?
I looked up July 29th in your Almanac and there was a total eclipse of the Sun that day what now?
You're just messing with me. Now. Look for yourself totality at 2:47 right over the western territories
Well, that's quite a thing, but I don't see how that affects wait
Unless you're suggesting right it was the perfect opportunity for McCready to escape that's absurd absurd like a fox
I guess
You say yourself that McCready was really good at remembering dates who would write about the Eclipse at any time and store that knowledge away
For the future like to give himself an advantage in a duel or something
All right, that's reasonable as far as it goes
But greedy wouldn't have worked the clips into the escape plan
because he didn't have anything to say over the court schedule you said with one the one thing in another the trial didn't start until
the July
25th McCready could have caused any number of those delays himself by faking illness in prison or messing with the horses on a ride in
Frisco or anything. Hmm. This could also explain the trial by combat
You mean there ended up being too much delay?
So if a regular trial went on too long, and he was found guilty. He would have missed the Eclipse
Exactly, whereas if he called for trial by combat, everything would be resolved one way or another and one only one more day
Maybe you'd win and that'd be fine. But if you'd lost you could use his escape plan
I have to admit this is pretty compelling but it's all maybes and what-ifs
Yeah, maybe it happened but maybe McCready was ready rescued by leprechauns. Oh, man, are there leprechauns in Frisco?
You need some kind of hard evidence before this is any more than just a fun story. It's what I mean
Well, let me ask you something else. Oh
My god, how can I find that evidence McCready's escaped?
Well, we don't even know that an escape happened true something like that would have been in the news for certain
Okay
Oh
Start at the bottom of the stack and flip through them
The main feature has to do with the clips in various axes and mostly all three minutes kids will be hanging
twenty-ninth and only two of them escape the confusion Oh
Keep looking you don't find anything relevant to the case
however
As you're putting more papers back a headline on the more recent issue husband of famous inventor missing the article is light on information
But apparently mrs
Gunn husband Dan vanished on the road while traveling to dirt water on business about six years ago law enforcement suspect bandits
But no evidence found that's kind of grim
okay, I
Mean, it's something we don't have names people definitely escaped where Carini could be alive
Man, this is a lot of back and forth for this one ghost
Got question for you. I found a newspaper article
The guy's scheduled to be executed today the clips escaped and one of them was never caught which one well didn't say which nope
Damn it and executed criminals aren't given gravestones with their names on them
So you can't just go looking around Frisco cemetery to find out listen mum Fleur
I really appreciate what you're trying to do with at this point
You would have actually had you would have to actually find McCready himself to prove. He wasn't executed due to my failure
Well, I guess that's what I'll do then
how the
How am I gonna find?
How am I gonna find McCready what
What
Right
Where in where would I find?
mccreaney, I don't know I have no idea where I'm McCready would be I don't even know what a
McCready is I'm going over to a third floor. I'm getting out of here cuz holy shit
Alright, that was a big reach around. Oh
God, I have been in here
Okay, did I get everything in here? I think I did boo. I think I did. I'm pretty sure anyway, right? Oh
Yeah, this ghost girl. I don't think I have I'll make tea from your tiny bones. Uh
Still not getting out. Can you speak I don't understand you. Goodbye - see ya. Bye
Was there anything in here that I missed us creepy place? Oh, the composition of this painting is bad
And that light on
Ye Oh
Looks like this is where the creepy music is coming from transcribe it. Okay, spooky lullaby music
U2's have transcribed the spooky lullaby under the sheet music or rather something use your hand to perform that operations
You don't actually know how to read music. Oh
Good
Great
I'll just take this here and play the lullaby
Where am I?
He seems to be waving a little oh look he's smiling, ah, he's so happy
Goodbye Oh, where did I go III feel like I disappeared which is also a problem
Well now that was nice. That was nice. Hey, can I oh but his stick
His stick I wanna stick
Alright I'm gonna go in the hedge maze outside cuz I think that's that's where I gotta go I
Think anyway cuz I haven't been there I've been deep in it
Anyway, there's gotta be something in here cuz I've got like hedge clippers and stuff like that. Loo shit. Oh, oh
That's where that was. Okay. Alright maze Oh
Locoweed. Oh wow
Yeah
You do a quick backflip and then make some funny noises by flapping your arms up and down with your hand in your armpit
the locoweed giggles loosening its fruits just enough for you to pluck a handful of
It out of the ground and bring it into a little bottle. Oh
All right Noor twerk clown wart
Okay, I think I've gotten these before tea bush tea tea
I don't know what that was all about meat bush
Frisco poppy there's so much stuff was a frisco poppy
Huh? Ah, that's nice. I don't think I can eat anything else in shock weed plant. Be careful. Oh
Wow arches point of impact under grow it Oh Bob
Sign says tokens only. Oh, I don't have any tokens
Would you look at this crazy thing destroy it dive in I'll fight it not fight it I don't want to waste my herbicide
I think I only got one more of those all
Right. Here we go. Come on. Oh my god. That's so much. Oh my god
I'm too powerful magic infused leaf. What is that?
So tingles with a magical energy that animated it when it was part of a malevolent topiary beast. Yeah. Okay, whatever
All right. Well, there's nothing here
All right, hey these might
Guys I got beans hey, that's awesome. Okay. So what I need to do is I need to go deliver the tea I need to
get a token and
I'm gonna get the token
I'm gonna go back to the well and I'm gonna deliver the tea in them and I'm gonna make the chili and then I'm gonna
Deliver the tea, so I got a no not here over here
Yeah and get this negotiate a better deal
No, I don't think I need a stamp token. I think it needs to be unstamped
That's the thing that would make sense to me. So that's what I'm gonna do
I mean, I I do have the brain of an ant and like the the wit of a shrew but you know
I'm thinking I'm thinking along the lines that maybe I might be on to something here. Hello
I was right you hold the token over to the well and try to think of something to wish for
After a few seconds you guys drop the token dang. I wish I had that token back
You're some chimes in a rope appears on the wishing wells crossbeams
Well, how about that? Oh
Oh
This wish was an accident anyway, so you feel entirely justified in taking your code token back. Oh
Okay, well that's what was it what what this shoot but there's already like
Kruk Oh freak me. Oh hell. Yeah. I actually have some tea. I went the wrong way
I actually have some tea Oh freak me. Oh, heck. Yeah. Oh heck and Hort. Oh shoot. Oh, oh
Fuck I get it. I did it. Hell. Yeah
Alright, so I need to go to the kitchen make some chili give it to the main man
All right. Let's do it throwing the spice tossing the beans
No
No, no God no God
No, God no God you restrain yourself from adding a gun step back and admire your handiwork
It's not according to Hoyle chili because it doesn't have a gun in it, but it is chili with no gun in it
Because Chili's seeding piece stole lace
Which is the thing you were after I got it. All right, let's get this gun
this guy
My cheeks hurt from smiling. I gotta honor of his on gun free. Chili. Oh, thank you. Alright. Oh wait
Well, it's something wrong. Well, I can only ghost food. How do I do you need me to murder this chili for you?
Not to put too fine a point on it. Yes. Alright. I'll try to find a humane way to do it. How do I murder?
How am I gonna murder this chili?
Do I shoot it so I need to shoot it, how'd I do that? Alright, let's go deliver the tea
Everything's so intricate here. Alright creepy little ghost girl. Hey want some deer
It's wonderful. She serves the tea in the four of you. Okay?
Well, not the dull sip it with your pinkies extended in genteel fashion then with a giggle in a wave she fades away
Rest in peace kiddo. Oh, thank God. I would never be over look at me
I'm shaking like a leaf
Kind of freaky situation, right?
Having to deal with the little kids freaks me out bad enough having to interact with the ghost of one. It was horrifying
Anyway, thanks for the rescue. I need to get back to work. What are you doing here?
I run the candy counter at the visitor center. Oh
Okay. Hello creepy doll. Okay. I
Guess by then sure thing creepy doll
Let go let's go visit the guy in the gun and the visitors center and then I gotta get out of here
Hello. Can I please see something?
Candy related please. Hello. Hello. Hi candy counter is open. Oh
This is not what I thought it was oh
The trick is making this kind of candy is that once the sugar is completely melted. You just keep melting it forever
whoa, the secret ingredient what makes it taste like gunpowder is gunpowder Oh,
Candy is full of cast off steel shavings from mrs. Guns Factory. Oh
Okay, well I don't exactly know what I would sell here
I don't remember any of these
Actually, I don't remember anything. Well, whatever. I'm not gonna sell anything. I don't need to meet so I'm just gonna
Wait, I do need something because I need I need that shot glass. I do need that. Okay, ghost pickle
I don't know if I need that
Uh, what can I scroll down? Oh, here we go bowling pin
Well, um, man, I just don't know what I needed what I don't need
Not getting rid of my spittoon at that's for damn sure. Um
So like
Sir just like something I could throw away. I don't know. What's good
And what's I guess I could throw away some of the old clothing. I have I
Think no, no
Small blue ribbon back if I sell those. I don't know how much I need to sell
How much do I need it for? What does it cost twelve hundred?
Say your name Bart. No, no, whatever
silicone ring I
Mean I guess I'll be enough. I don't need the ring. It's not a new item. It's an old item actually
Huh?
Yes, a spider pie I could sell that spider omelette I mean, I don't think I need this ring, right
You would I
Know I'm selling it. Whatever fucking here we go. Give me that shit. I don't know why
You got personalized gun
Miter shot glass this personalized souvenir shot glass from gun Manor you're excited to use it now that you're finally old enough to drink
Gain, XP when you drink booze, that's it
That's it
That that's it really that is it that's all like okay, you know what whatever that's those totally worth 1,200 bones
Okay, whatever so we're gonna end this here
We got a lot more to explore because I think we got something in the order of eight or nine
Seven, hey, we're doing much better
Okay, we got seven ghosts deal with and we're all in like general final stages of dealing with them
We just got a long way to go. So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think down the comments below if you haven't seen the rest of west of loathing
I'll put a link in the description below check out out tons of episode funds here is all really funny
Really cool to see my face is gonna heal up soon. So thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always I will see you in the next video